البرلمان قابله الاطار التنسيقي
بمظاهرة شعبية دعت بعض الاطراف
تنتقل من المرتبة الثانية الى
الاولى عالميا في الصناعات
العسكرية. شاركونا برأيكم? وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تنشر مشاهد من
على السواحل التركية وماذا عن
الالغام في البحر الاسود.
الجوي التيواني. خبير امريكي.
امريكا لا ترغب بمواجهة عسكرية
قوة اقتصادية وسياسية. ومن
الجزائر الى العراق الجريح. وبعد
مصادر طاقة بديلة قبل حلول فصل
الشتاء. وزير الخارجية الروسي
اوكرانيا هذا بينما بدأت عملية
تفتيش اول سفينة حبوب اوكرانية
طربينا اخر في خط نول ستريم وان
اوروبا تسابق الزمن للبحث عن
ايضا بوجوده للاستخبارات
الامريكية. وتم التواصل واطلاع
خطط ايرانية لنقل مئات من
الطائرات المسيرة المقاتلة بدون
زاخاروفا عن زيارة بيلوسي
لتايوان ان الولايات المتحدة
الامريكي ومستشارة الامن الداخلي
عن هذه المعلومات ليتم التواصل
الابيض جيك سوليفان عن معلومات
استخباراتية رفعت عنها سرية عن
وجود زوجة الظواهري وابنته
واحفاده في المنزل زاد الشكوك
الرئيسي لهجمات الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر كيف نجحت الاستخبارات
الجديد والمرعب والذي لا مثيل له
في العالم. والذي قد يطال امريكا
ودول الناتو ويحمل رؤوسا نووي.
سرعته تعادل تسعة اضعاف سرعة
الارض وبالتحديد موسكو اذ اعلن
بوتين للعالم عن صاروخ تسيركون
اثنين من اكبر مساعدي بايدن وهما
نائب مستشار الامن القومي
الصوت وهو خارق ولا يمكن
اعتراضه. وها هو اليوم الخدمة?
قاعدة بليسيتس الفضائية يحمل
قمرا صناعيا عسكريا. وقالت
مباشرة مع الصين. امريكا تستهزئ
بالصين وبكين تظهر عاجزة حتى
الصين بحرب التصريحات ليسخر منها
المجتمع الدولي? وبرأيكم هل هناك
الوزارة في بيان لها ان عمليات
اطلاق الصاروخ تمت في الوضع
تحت سيطرة القوات الروسية.
وامريكا تعلن عن ارسال حزمة
اتصال مع واشنطن لتهدئة التوتر.
فماذا انتم فاعلون? هل ستكتفي
التايوانية من الطائرات الصينية.
وتحركات امريكية عسكرية متزايدة
التركية التي تستخدمها القوات
الاوكرانية. وزارة الخزانة
الاحداث والتطورات. قالت الناطقة
باسم الخارجية الروسية ماريا
ما كل هذا الرعب الذي يحمله
اعلان بوتين هذا? نهاية الرجل
مقربة من هذا الهدف هل الرواية
الامريكية برأيكم حقيقية?
الدفاع الصينية سنشن عمليات
عسكرية وعلى اهداف محددة ردا على
هذه الزيارة ودفاعا عن السيادة
الوطنية. لتنفذ الصين مناورات
الذي يحدث او بالاحرى ما الذي
سيحدث. تايوان في قلب توتر صيني
التايوانية ان احدى وعشرين
مقاتلة صينية دخلت مجال الدفاع
على المنطقة باي لحظة. حيث
انتشرت مقاطع للجيش الصيني وهو
زيارة بيلوسي الى تايوان لا تمثل
انتهاكا لسيادة الصين او لسياسة
تتوسع بين واشنطن وبكين. الرد
الصيني. الصيني قد ينفث النار
بمفاجآتها وانتقلت من الارض الى
احتلال الفضاء عسكريا. فهل
السياسية العراقي الى الحوار
للتوصل الى خفض التصعيد. الجيش
تصاعد الازمة السياسية في العراق
واعلان التيار الصدري اعتصاما في
ينقل اسلحة ومعدات عسكرية حديثة
تشمل دبابات ومدرعات وانظمة
الهدف قبل ثواني من لحظة
الاستهداف لقتل كل من يوجد على
ووضعها قسم التعليقات. روسيا
تحتل الفضاء عسكريا. اعلنت وزارة
الامريكية تدرج عشرات الشركات
والافراد المرتبطين بروسيا في
الجزائري عبدالمجيد تبون يلوح
برغبة بلاده الانضمام لمجموعة
سيناريوهات محتملة لرد صيني?
اتمنى منكم مشاركة ارائكم معنا
عدوانية في مضيق تايوان. ولدينا
خمسة تحالفات عسكرية في منطقة
لاثارة غضب الصين. سفينتان
حربيتان بريطانيتان تصلان الى
التزام واشنطن بحماية تايوان
وبصداقة والشراكة مع تايبي وان
سيرجي لافروف ان زيارة بيروسيوان
محاولة متعمدة من جانب واشنطن
مساعدات عسكرية لاوكرانيا بقيمة
خمسمائة وخمسين مليون دولار.
المحيطين الهادئ والهندي. وهذا
ما سيكبح جماح الصين وسيجعلها
موسكو تهدد بقطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسية مع واشنطن اذا قرر
قائمة العقوبات الجديدة. روسيا
تنفذ تهديدها لاوروبا وتوقف
ستستفيد الصين من الهيمنة
الروسية على الفضاء في غزو
عقولنا قليلا? كما انهم صرحوا ان
وزن الصاروخ الواحد خمسة واربعين
الان مع تهديدات لفظية بغزو
تايوان. اما روسيا مستمرة
كيلو جراما وهو موجه بالليزر
ويحتوي على ست سكاكين او? تصيب
امريكي. عناوينه متعددة وتجلياته
واضحة. اختراق متكرر للاجواء
الاوكراني يعلن استعادة اكثر من
خمسين بلدة في محيط خرسون كانت
بريكس. وقال تبون ان مجموعة
بريكس تهم الجزائر بالنظر لكونها
جديدة قد تنهي الازمة. ها هي
تغادر. نعم قالت سادخل تايوان
الساعة السادسة وثماني عشرة
دقيقة صباحا بصاروخين من نوع
في مضيق تايوان. الصين تايوان
ارض صينية للصين بالقوة. ليرد
رئيسة تايوان قالت ان زيارتها
الى تايوان تهدف للتعبير عن
حتى طلقة رصاص. فلماذا ازعجتمونا
وازعجتم العالم بكل هذه
طيار الى روسيا. ولكن ما حاجة
روسيا بهذه الطائرات وهي التي
حينها مع مدير سي اي ايه
ومسؤولين اخرين. وتم التنفيذ
الكونجرس اعلان روسيا دولة راعية
للارهاب. كشفت وزارة الدفاع
بسوس هذا العصر؟ واليوم تقول
انتهيت من مهمتي في تايوان.
عودة للصين ام توترات عاتية تسطو
على بحر جنوب الصين وجبهة التوتر
ان اسرته واحفاده وابنته بنفس
المنزل. فلماذا لم يحترموا
تعمل على زعزعة الاستقرار في
العالم. كشف مستشار القومي للبيت
العمليات القتالية لانظمة والتي
نتج عنها تدمير واسقاط مسيرة
ولوحت بيدها وغادرت دون ان تغادر
فوهة مدافع الصين اي قذيفة او
قال بوتين اضرب ثم فاوض. نانسي
بيلوسي قبل مغادرتها وبحضور
تهدد بقطع العلاقات الدبلوماسية
مع واشنطن. الجزائر تحضر لمفاجأة
وتايوان تطلق نداء استغاثة من
الغضب الصيني. ولهذا السبب موسكو
استطاعوا تحديد مكان الظواهري
بمنطقة شيربول الافغانية. كما ان
التهديدات؟ امريكا لا تؤمن بلغة
التصريح بل تؤمن بلغة الفعل وكما
نأمل من امريكا فهم اهمية
وحساسية قضية تايوان ونحن على
المركزية الامريكية في استهداف
الظواهري جواسيس امريكيون
الخارجية الصينية قائلة ان هذا
انتهاك خطير لسيادة الصين وسلامة
الغامض. بعد مطاردته على مدار
واحد وعشرين عاما بوصفه المخطط
وردة فعلها لن يكون لها مبرر لان
التبرير قد اتى بالفعل واضافت
الدفاع الروسية عن اطلاق صاروخ
سيوز تو بوينت وان في الفضائي من
البرقدار تتساقط في اوكرانيا?
كيف ذلك? روسيا توفي بوعدها
تهديدات الصين لا تخيفنا. ولقد
رأيتم لم يحدث شيء. سفينتان
اراضيها. ووصفت الخارجية الصينية
الزيارة بانها استفزاز ملحوظ
الطبيعي وتم التحكم في اطلاق
الصاروخ وتحليقه. فما هي مهمة
هذا الصاروخ العسكري وما الذي
تخطط له روسيا ومن الفضاء الى
واعلنوا قتله هو فقط. مهلا ما كل
هذه الدقة يا سادة. الم يخبرونا
رسالتها عن طريق زيارة بيلوسي
الى تايوان. وهنا الرد من وزارة
صواريخ من مدينة شيامن الى
فوجيان اقرب مدينة لتايوان. ما
التي يتوقع الجيش التايواني ان
الغزو سيبدأ منها. لتعلق وزيرة
تايوان?
الامريكية. وقد شهدنا تحركات
عسكرية صينية مزعجة واكثر
تراجع اوراقها. اانت متأكد يا
جون كيربي فلدى الصين كذلك
تغيير الوضع الراهن بشكل احادي
وانها لا تدعم استقلال تايوان
الامريكية قيادة الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي الذي قال ان
وبالذخيرة الحية في ستة مواقع
قرب تايوان هي نفسها المواقع
الامريكان. سنتدخل عسكريا ان
اقدمتم على ذلك لترسل امريكا
الصين الواحدة. وتهديدات الصين
لا تخيف الولايات المتحدة
تحالفات وتمنى الا تنسى انت كذلك
واضاف كيربي ان واشنطن تعرض
التضامن الامريكي معها حاسم
لتصرح بعدها من قناة سي ان ان
مهلا يا كيربي هذا انفصام في
الشخصية ام انك تحاول انشاء خط
فلم تعقها طائرات الصين ولا
اساطيلها العسكرية. ماذا تقصد
اقتصادية هي الاولى عربيا
والعراق الجريح يخرج بمبادرة
وتنفذ تهديدها لاوروبا عن فاجعة
عسكرية قد تطال حلف الناتو
حربيتان بريطانيتان تصلان
اوكرانيا. ما الذي يحدث وطائرة
اضرب ثم فاوض. هكذا قالها بوتين
ليعطي درسا للصين. ترد امريكا.